-Our next guest is
an Emmy Award-winning
stand-up comedian
and an actress you know
from the TV series "Hannibal
and films
such as "Ocean's Thirteen"
and "Victoria & Abdul."
Her new movie,
"Six Minutes to Midnight,"
comes to theaters and Demand
on March 26th.
Let's take a look.
-So what brings you here,
Mr. Miller?
What sort of Englishman
would accept a post
teaching Herr Hitler's
League of German Girls?
[ Speaking German ]
-I do not like surprises.
I will place you
on a trial period.
-Please welcome back
to the show Eddie Izzard.
How are you?
-I'm very good.
How are you doing?
-I'm good.
It's been a very long time
since you've been here,
seven years, I believe...
-I know.
-...and I'm so happy
to have you back.
-I wanted to stay away
for seven years,
as absence makes the heart
grow fonder.
Something like that.
Yeah.
But it seems like yesterday.
Didn't we have a chat
at "Saturday Night Live"?
We talk together?
-We have.
Yes, absolutely.
-One of the times
I turned up there.
But, yeah. No, I've been
watching your "Closer Look."
I get it. Because I don't know
if your show
totally comes over here
to Britain
because, you know,
sometimes bits come over,
but I've been watching it
for ages and then, they said
"Hey, come and do that."
Great. Excellent.
Fun to talk to you.
-It's even nicer when people
who watch the show agree
to come on
because most of our guests
aren't aware
of what we're doing here.
-No. I see you go in
and you're fighting the fight,
which is great, you know,
because I've got this hat,
which is...
And that's what I do
on my marathons and raise money.
I don't know where I got "Make
Humanity Great Again" from
It just came to me one night
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm like, "Oh, yeah.
I think there's another slogan
like that out there somewhere.
-Yes. I think you
got there first.
I think you got there first.
Now, you mentioned marathons
and you're not being --
This isn't just,
"I ran a marathon, ha ha ha.
You have just finished --
and we've talked about thi
in the past.
You've just finished
32 marathons in 31 days,
which, obviously --
You raised ££200,000,
which is amazing.
But just talk us through how
you even go about that.
-I've got to say I did more.
A third of a million,
we got to, ££333,000.
and George Clooney
was counting it down.
Basically, I was doing it
on a treadmill.
You know, it's COVID lockdown,
so, yeah, every day,
I was doing a marathon
and doing a stand-up gig
at the end,
which is kind of crazy,
but, you know,
you try to raise money.
I've done a few of these before,
but I was talking to peopl
for six hours.
I mean, you do your show,
you talk to people.
I was doing six hours of thi
every day,
chatting to people
and running on a thing,
which actually was good for me
because it was
so mindlessly boring,
running on a treadmill.
So I do this.
I raise money.
You know, I want to be
a member of parliament.
But, meanwhile,
I'm doing my film
"Six Minutes to Midnight,"
in which I do a lot of running
But Make Humanity Great Agai
is my slogan
and it includes
all Americans in it.
People say, "That's not good
for America."
No, Americans are in humanity.
Everyone's included,
7.8 billion.
And George Clooney
was counting down the number
as we did the last
double marathon on the last day.
So it was a beautiful thin
to do, kind of crazy.
-So you did a double maratho
the last day.
And I will say,
it all sounds impossible,
but, as you mentioned,
it strikes me as so much harde
on a treadmill
than it would be
in the great outdoors.
-For the brain,
it's just mind-bogglingly --
I thought we would talk to two
or three people a day.
As soon as I got going on this
I said,
"Just line the people up.
I need to talk."
Talk about anything --
cats and dogs and trees
and helicopters --
to get my mind off this endles
pounding and not going anywhere.
And, you know, so,
it was good, in the end.
And I talked to some
wonderful people.
And, you know, the people
you're raising the money for i
for charities all
around the world.
So, yeah, it was
a beautiful thing to do.
I'm just kind of bonkers
and out there,
so I do this stuff.
-You shared with us.
This was in The Guardian,
which, you really have
taken away
the marathon bragging rights
Basically, we have a character
here, saying,
"Will you sponsor me
for my marathon?"
"But you only ran the one.
And then, "Damn you,
Eddie Izzard!
You've spoilt it for everyone!
And I think
most marathon runners
would probably say
that you have effectively
spoilt it.
-I have, a little bit,
but other people
have done as well.
My dad cut that
out of The Guardian
newspaper in Britain
and he put it next to my bed
when I came home to visit him,
so that's kind of nice.
My dad.
I thought my dad wasn't
really into my career,
but he seemed to collect
everything from my career.
But, yeah, so marathon running
is something I can do.
Because, if you are
a trans person, as you know,
you said actress there
[indistinct]
but I'm gender fluid
and this is a male role
that I've played.
I've been out for 36 years
but people suddenly
sort of noticed it,
which is a bit weird.
Like, "Oh, you're suddenly tall!
What?
You didn't give us any notice.
Thirty-six years' notice, guys
So everyone -- It's great.
Thank you so much.
It's a great honor
to be promoted,
but I'm pretty fluid.
I see in boy mode
and girl mode,
like a superhero thing.
That's how I see transgender
And so I can be either one
or the other
and, this film,
"Six Minutes to Midnight,"
is set in the hometown
where my dad grew up
and I grew up,
in this girls' school.
Judi Dench plays the woman
running this girls' school
which is full of the daughters
of the Nazi High Command,
and goddaughters.
Himmler's goddaughter
was actually at this school,
in a seaside town in England
learning English,
these German girls used
to hang out
with the other right-wing people
in the British aristocracy
Edward VIII was very into Hitler
and you'll probably know
this kind of history.
So I didn't even know
this was the truth,
but the school badge
had a British flag
and a Nazi flag on it
and I thought,
"Whoa!
There's a film in that."
So the basis of the story
is true --
real girls at this school
doing this stuff --
and then, we've written
a thriller on top of it,
Judi Dench, myself,
and Jim Broadbent.
-Obviously, you are
a very accomplished writer
but you had never written
a screenplay before.
Did you find it daunting?
Did you enjoy that process
-Yeah. You were talking
to Amy Poehler.
She said don't do writing,
you know, this thing.
Because you're obviously
a wildly experienced writer,
but, you know, I come
from where you've lived
a lot of your life,
that shorter sketch thing?
I came from sketch.
Then I went to stand-up.
I had to learn
a whole new different thing.
I couldn't do stand-up.
I broke into Pinewood Studio
when I was 15.
And Steven Spielberg, I think,
worked at Universal
when he was
about 17, 18, you know,
so I was trying to do
this similar thing.
He got his career going bam!
And mine took
30, 40 years, you know.
[ Laughter ]
The fine-wine approach
to careers.
Because I knew I didn't know
how to do story structure,
character --
I didn't have the sense of it,
so I wrote
with two other writers.
And this has obviously
got a powerful thing
because like the message was
from the 1930s
and then, you had this thing
particularly in America,
you got Brexit,
you've got Trump,
the same kind of thing.
You've got the
Alternative for Deutschlan
in Germany again,
and Marine Le Pen,
all this right-wing thinking
around the world,
which is like going back
to the 1930s,
as we're trying
to drag the world to the 2030s
and say, "Let's move forward."
And some people, it's like
"No, let's go back.
Let's have another go
at the 1930s.
How did it turn out last time?
[ Laughter ]
Our film has, hopefully,
got a message in there
that is, you know, "If you
do not learn from history,
you're doomed to repeat it."
And, now, more than ever,
it's just resonating.
And our film sits there, right
on the eve of World War II
These girls,
the fight for hearts and minds
-Well, congratulations
on the film.
Congratulations, again,
32 marathons, 31 days,
a third of a million pounds.
And it is just a delight
to see you, as always.
Please come back soon.